jamais vu un simple couse pour rencontrer Sally
courrier non distribuable se disputer est ce
juste un million de catalane
contre du plutonium en 1985 quand vous avez eu le
contremaître pouvez-vous rester disponible et vous l'avez
dit parce que j'avais un train et je suis
retourné pour l'aider à réparer son  inter oh
ouais c'était vrai ou c'était t'étais timide
ou t'étais prétentieux à ce moment là
où je vivais peut et revenant à
Sarah c'est parce que petite
maison de production pour produire le film ils n'avaient pas
d'argent et je n'aimais pas  me battre
avec lui et je suis parti et il a fallu très
peu de temps à la télévision pour exprimer mon
attitude et mon approche du problème
et j'ai trouvé juste très vite que j'étais
occupé avec autre chose et c'était
drôle pour en partie pour les gens et très
sérieusement  pris problème ouais sur moi
et les films et la culture dans mon pays
tu avais à l'époque tu avais beaucoup de
propositions mais tu refusais de travailler
ailleurs qu'en Yougoslavie tu as
peur de perdre ton âme mon âme et mon
éducation et tout ce que je sais à propos  la vie est
ma jambe ajustée que je prends avec moi avec mes
souvenirs et toutes ces choses
sortent d'une manière ou d'une autre dans les films
et j'avais peur de tous les scripts
qu'ils m'ont proposés que l'un de ces
moments de ma vie je peux mettre en  le
film et puis un jour vous avez lu un
magazine un journal appelé Express
política vous savez tout et vous
trouvez l'histoire de gitans prenant des enfants
et les vendant en Europe en Europe de l'
Ouest et vous avez alors décidé de faire un
film avec ça le premier signal était très
fort parce que vous savez que c'est quelqu'un
avec les enfants et que vous pouvez entendre que
quelqu'un va s'énerver quand je
commence à penser au film j'ai vu la
première réaction n'est rien à faire
pour faire le film Urgences ce que je faisais
tout  le temps du tournage après le
scénario qui est basé sur l'histoire vraie
pendant le tournage j'essayais de trouver
tous les niveaux culturels des gitans vivants
et accros
à ici et puis vous avez un ami très proche
du contremaître du village et moi  t
montrera le script pour le raconter avec
connaissance et vous savez et j'ai été presque
très chanceux à la fin ouais parce qu'alors
il s'est battu pour que ce ne soit pas
juste après que je vous ai donné l'argent il
m'a donné l'argent
et les trois jours  après que j'ai commencé à
tirer, il est parti